lentamente la población de tigres va en
aumento se cree que el número de tigres
que vive en libertad en tailandia se ha
duplicado en los últimos años cumpliendo
un compromiso internacional que el país
asumió en 2010
a nivel mundial en el último siglo el
número de tigres ha pasado de 100.000 a
unos pocos miles
pero tailandia no sigue esa tendencia
en esta reserva natural del oeste del
país 21 equipos de guardas forestales se
encargan de ayudar a proteger a los
tigres que viven aquí están entrenados
para detectar señales de los grandes
felinos
competimos
estas son huellas de tigre el rayo la
tierra aquí para marcar su territorio
eso significa que esta es su zona de
casa ahora
la hora del descubrimiento y las
coordenadas gps se registran
cuidadosamente la edad
todos los equipos tienen que informar de
las pruebas de actividad de los tigres y
eso nos permite señalar zonas
específicas en las que debemos desplegar
más patrullas para protegerlos mejor de
cada tema
los cuartos también cuentan con unas 500
cámaras repartidas por la reserva para
identificar a los cazadores furtivos que
se infiltran en el parque estos dos
hombres armados fueron detenidos poco
después de ser vistos
los cazadores furtivos cazan tigres por
sus pieles para usarlas como decoración
a veces son personas ricas que tienen
una cabeza de tigre como trofeo para
demostrar lo poderosos que son
[Música]
gracias a los esfuerzos de los guardas
de esta reserva de fauna salvaje el
número de tigres se ha casi duplicado en
12 años pasando de 42 individuos en 2010
a unos 80 en la actualidad se calcula
que hay un total de 200 tigres salvajes
en tailandia
acaso es tailandia un modelo para la
protección de esta especie en las zonas
turísticas como aquí en batalla la
realidad es otra han aparecido parques
temáticos como éste tiger park
de tantas
de
cali
por 50 euros los visitantes pueden tomar
todas las fotos que quieran con tigres
de todas las edades
[Música]
he visto tigres en televisión antes pero
esta es la primera vez que he podido
tocarlos son tan bonitos es mejor que
estén aquí en jaulas en la naturaleza
asustan a la gente
posar para las fotos con niños pequeños
están muy lejos del hábitat natural de
los grandes felinos en los bosques de
tailandia aquí los tigres son tratados
como si fueran un gato doméstico
normal sabes en realidad soy amante de
los perros soy amante de los animales si
pudiera pasar todo el día aquí lo harían
los tigres aún tienen sus garras pero
han sido limadas por seguridad a pesar
de su aspecto plácido los felinos no
están drogados según la dirección dicen
que cuidan de los animales y que la
atracción es algo más que un negocio
nuestro principal objetivo es salvar la
población de tigres y permitir que la
gente esté más cerca de ellos para
aprender cómo viven
sí porque cada vez tenemos más tigres
incluso acabamos de abrir un nuevo
parque en tu que hay varios parques de
tigres como este en el país
para esta activista de la vida salvaje
van en contra de los objetivos de
conservación de tailandia
es la explotación de la vida silvestre
solo dinero dinero dinero tenemos más de
2 mil tigres en cautiverio en tailandia
en este momento mientras que tenemos tal
vez alrededor de 200 en la naturaleza
para que no sirve para nada la
conservación y creo que como tailandia
está haciendo un gran trabajo
protegiendo la población salvaje de
tigres deberíamos acabar con estos
increíbles
explotación o conservación la cuestión
ética sobre el turismo de tigres no
parece ser algo que tailandia quiere
abordarlo